them
I have a few Communications
first of all on the decisions of various
committees
and the starting of
inter-institutional
negotiations under rule 71 one
has announced on Monday the 2nd of
October the president of the ECR group
and the ID group
and various individual members
to reach the minimum threshold
on the 71 to
relating to a decision of the Libre
decision to start negotiations
for the following procedure
border code
the vote will be held tomorrow
concerning the other decisions to enter
into negotiations I have received no
request for a vote in Parliament
by members or a political group or
groups
reaching at least the medium threshold
the Committees May therefore start
negotiations
so
we return to the agenda the first item
for today's debate is the council and
commission statements on the need for a
speedy adoption of the Asylum and
migration package
alongside colleagues
I would like to welcome the
representatives of the
commission and Council I would like to
give the floor to the representative of
the Council secretary of state
Mr Pascual Navarro Rios I'd like to give
in the floor for his remarks
senior president president
ladies and gentlemen commissioner vice
president commissioner
before going into the topic on the
agenda the urgency
of adopting this package allow me to
briefly refer to the external dimension
of migration
we've had a debate on the mou with
Tunisia 12th of September in this
Parliament since then we have seen chaos
in lampedusa thousands of persons
arriving in a very short space of time
the figures are on the rise all of these
Maritime routes
Central Mediterranean very high numbers
we've seen an increase of irregular
arrivals
through the Greek Islands Cyprus
canaries as well as Peninsula Spain
these figures mean that we have to act
holistically we have a 10 point plan for
lampedusa from the Commission in
accordance with that we need to address
a number of areas and we need to address
both internal and external dimensions of
migration
in the council meeting Justice and home
Affairs 28th of September the president
put forward a proposal in terms of the
external orientation of our migration
policy in the EU and we would like to
have long-term
collaboration with countries of Transit
and orange and there was unanimous
support for our proposal in addition to
which an efficient management of
migration in the EU means that we have
to tackle both the internal and external
Dimension both have to be fully
functional in other words Asylum
applications for persons seeking help
will be dealt with fairly and
individuals who do not meet the
requirements for protection will be
returned to the countries of origin
whilst fully respecting human rights and
whilst fully respecting also the
principle of no return
that now brings us on to the main point
of this debate this pact on Asylum and
migration Council on several occasions
has said that this pact is a fundamental
importance if we are to guaranteeing our
common Asylum system if we want to
respond effectively to situations such
as the ones that we've seen recently in
lampedusa during the summer we made
considerable progress in our
inter-institutional negotiations
regarding the different parts of this
pact different proposals
and as co-legislators we are determined
to move forward we want to adopt the
necessary reform of this Asylum system
and we want to do it by the end of this
term this cycle
tripartite discussions regarding Asylum
regarding the management of Asylum
immigration are being held regularly we
have different positions in some of the
positions between Council and Parliament
important differences but we are moving
closer together we're trying to seek
rapprochement
regarding the crisis regulation so far
we've not managed to reach an agreement
for a date to start negotiations
in agreement with Council
notwithstanding that I think we're very
close to a result in the Justice and
home Affairs Council 28th of September a
great number of member states expressed
their support to a new draft text to
this proposal we are confident we think
that this mandate will be supported by a
broad majority soon that would allow us
to start inter-institutional
negotiations and we also believe that we
will be able to settle the main issues
that need to be settled by the end of
this cycle by the end of this term and I
very much hope that the tripartite
dialogues will resume as soon as
possible regarding the control
regulation and the eurodac regulation
also I very much hope
that we will be able to start or restart
all negotiations on this very important
proposal and to do so soon we have no
time to lose
particularly bearing in mind recent
events in central Mediterranean thank
you very much for your kind attention
thank you thank you very much and I'll
turn to the commission and I give the
floor to vice president sheenas
honorable members
before I start let me on behalf of the
European commission express our feelings
of Sympathy for the terrible accident
yesterday in Venice our thoughts are
with the families of the victims and the
Italian people
uh
for the last four years
in the Commission in the current
political cycle when we had to deal with
migration
we were obliged to work at the same time
as Architects and firefighters
architects of a new regulatory framework
that would be cohesive holistic Global
and that would connect all the dots of a
missing European migration and Asylum
policy
and at the same time as fire
firefighters being obliged to cope with
an endless series a sequence of Crisis
both at our external borders and in
other parts of our territory
on the architect's track
I thank you for putting our Asylum and
migration packed on top of this house
political agenda
recent events once more so that we need
a European migration policy
we need the pact and we need it now
the clock has run out on us on how long
we can live in a house half built
parallel to this regulatory work
we see every day our problems emerging
the cost of non-europe emerging on
migration as we continue to work on the
firefighting fronts reacting to
different events on a case-by-case basis
with ad hoc tools and in a patchwork
regulatory environment
this produces some results
it brings us some successes but it
prevents us from reaching the full
efficiency unity and solidarity I am
convinced I know we can achieve
we have all seen the recent images from
LA pedusa and we still have similar
images in my mind in our mind from
everos from the belarusia border with
Poland and our Baltic states theota
we have seen the central Mediterranean
route
nearly 127 000 people have reached the
EU so far from this route almost the
double compared to the period last year
there are increasing arrivals to the
Greek Islands as well as to the Canary
Islands
and of course there continue to be
secondary movements mainly towards
Germany France and Belgium
more than 600 000 people applied for
Asylum this year
showing many also arrive legally in
Europe
and over 4 million Ukrainian refugees
continue to benefit from our blanket
temporary protection status
we are addressing these challenges
together at the same time
we just renewed the status of temporary
protection for Ukrainian refugees until
March 2025.
we presented an effective 10-point plan
to support Italy
reinforcing our support to itably to
Italy notably through our work on the
ground and our EU agencies
we're stepping up border surveillance at
Sea and in the air and we are supporting
proper registration of all people
arriving
parallel to that we are reaching on the
ground reaching out to countries of
origin and transit in Africa and
elsewhere
I have last week traveled to Ivory Coast
Senegal and guinea
and I will travel next week to
Mauritania and Gambia
we are working with these countries of
origin to make sure
that they understand that have much more
to benefit from the European Union
by working with us rather against us
and we have of course stepped up the
implementation of the memorandum of
understanding with Tunisia
in very specific circumstances also
concerning fundamental rights
finally
we are putting in place for November a
very ambitious
legal migration framework a talent
partnership that would align our jobs in
the our vacancies in our job markets
with available offer and expertise from
the countries of origin that want to
establish good working relations with in
this aspect this scheme would certainly
allow tunisians to learn new skills and
help meet the severe labor shortages
hampering growth in our job market
whilst we're addressing this
firefighting challenges
we see
and we come to an obvious conclusion
unless we are able to address all this
issue to get all these issues together
at the same time globally
we will never fully overcome these
problems
we must now put in place a common
European migration and Asylum system
one that we have been building
passionately over the last three years
and we are now very close to completing
A system that addresses all our
difficulties all our problems
with fast procedures at the border to
identify Asylum or return
with mandatory solidarity helping member
states Under Pressure obliging all
member states to contribute according to
their ability and needs
with a reinforced returns system for
those who have no right to be under our
protection
umbrella
and mutually beneficial migration
Partnerships with countries of origin
Transit and destination to find the
Smugglers who bring death to our seas
and to develop safe legal Pathways to
Europe
all this in one package is called the EU
Asylum and migration Pact
we have come very far
much farther than we did dream
four years ago
formerly divisive files like the blue
cards and the Asylum agency are now
adopted
inter-institutional trilogues are
underway for almost every single
proposal in The Pact
and as we speak querido secretario
core repair is debating the last Missing
Link of the package the crisis
regulation
like you
all of you
I keenly await the core repair outcome
and hope that the ambassadors the
permanent representatives of Our member
states will understand the need to
produce this agreement why while the
house of European democracy is debating
the Asylum and migration Pact
honorable members
time is running out
in few months there will be elections
we need the pact done and dusted before
Europeans go out to vote
I call you
I ask you that once we have the green
light from the council you adopt your
mandate also on the return directive and
continue try logs on all other files
the whole of Europe is now watching us
measuring carefully my word I would say
history is watching us
if we fail
then we will give fuel to the false
claims made by the enemies of democracy
by Russian disinformation
that Europe is incapable of managing
migration
but if we succeed
we will show that Europe can unite on
this issue that's so important to our
citizens
I remain convinced
that the biggest incentive for irregular
migration probably the biggest pull
factor is the lack of a European
migration and Asylum system
loopholes in the system we have today
continue to be exploited and abused by
Smugglers
and this will remain the case until we
make a difference
we have so much to be proud of our Union
we are the largest and better regulated
internal Market in the world we have the
second strongest currency in the world
we are the champions of Human Rights
privacy Healthcare education and
democracy we have everything except a
common migration and Asylum policy
worthy of the name
three years ago when we presented The
Pact that
we knew at the time that it would not be
an easy Journey
and our progress so far has been as
remarkable as it has been complex
we are so close now
but it will require sustained efforts
from both this house and the council
but above all
it will require courage
The Carriage of our conviction and the
courage to take necessary compromises
we will not rebuild the Parthenon
but we now have a window of opportunity
where everybody can agree upon thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you very much Vice President we
now come to the representatives of the
groups
I would like to start with Madrid Weber
yeah
vice president vice president
Council representative colleagues
Europe helps
the right of assembler the UN Refugee
convention are
essential for our continent we have no
more refugees than ever in Europe
at least over 3 million in Ukraine we're
not a fortress we help more
uh Asylum Seekers than any other
continent is part of our DNA
we have
borders a lot of problems with
capacities a lot of Mayors say that
there's no housing left in Italy Greece
Etc we're told that the figures must go
down
and we have external borders where the
Coast Guard should be in control not the
uh
these people provide an essential
service they save people but they also
control and we also need Solutions
the
the agreement with Tunisia is important
90 of boats start there we can
have a humanitarian control of our
borders if we do it in cooperation with
our
neighbors I'd like to thank the Dutch
German governments and Mrs Von the lion
for this agreement I would like Olaf
Schultz and Mr macron
um accept this agreement we can only do
with in partnership with tuna Tunisia
even though it's difficult this
agreement is an example for other
agreements in North Africa the migration
pact the second solution we need after
seven years of debate
the Czech uh president managed to
achieve a breakthrough the commission Mr
skeenass has done the essential work
the parliament has done its bit we're
nearly there we want to close by the end
of the year it's
up to Mrs is Funderland to get these
majorities it won't solve the all the
problems as long as Africa is poor and
Europe is Rich there will be migrants
but
we can control things together
and we can secure Schengen within Europe
I would like to go to some of the
incorrect elements in the discussion
we've had discussions about securing
borders if we need fences
we have the longest um
fence in Melania in
in north of Africa
the green Minister
gave the green light for putting up a
fence in Finland
and Denmark is discussing whether we
uh we should carry out uh Asylum
procedures outside the EU that's being
proposed by social Democrats
and uh
there's a talk of a new acts axis
between fitzo and Orban fitzo uh doesn't
want to play along with the migration
impact the previous government under the
Epp
leadership were on board I would like to
have Clarity from the social Democrats
in this discussion where do you stand
we'll have we'll have a lot of talk
about uh moving to the right on
migration issues I'd like to hear what
the social Democrats think about
the Italian government is taking all
refugees they've opened their port the
French interior Minister I don't want to
have any migrants from lampedusa in
France
um there's sending troops to the Italian
borders
um there's financing in Germany but the
but they don't want to take refugees
rescued in in from boats in the
Mediterranean that's the the incorrect
elements and
in the discussion we have and that must
come to an end colleagues that's the
truth we face
we the option is either we succeed and
we can close this open wound in Europe I
agree this is a historical issue we Face
perhaps the biggest and most important
reform in this legislative term uh to
conclude on that if we don't succeed uh
that'll be a program for the populace
and we need to prevent that together
thank you very much
the next speaker is Gabriella Bischoff
thank you foreign
thank you very much president there are
those who Express things more
diplomatically others more directly
migration policy as it currently stands
has failed why is this not because so
many people are coming to the continent
of Europe but because many want to have
the advantages of membership of the
European Union but when it comes to
hosting refugees they want to leave that
to their neighbors or they refuse to
register the refugees simply hoping that
they will move on speedily I think that
this lack of solidarity must be
addressed
and this must be at the very heart of
our new migration Pact
just because we are unable to act
effectively doesn't mean that we can be
Outsourcing our responsibilities to
Tunisia giving them cash to solve our
problems this is completely wrong we
need to resolve our issues here and we
need a migration package which is based
on our values and which indicates that
we can practice solidarity and manage
these problems member states where
refugees arrive have to be able to
manage the problems but those of
destination likewise the secretary of
state has talked about the Tunisia
package and said where you can dream all
you like but the way things are
currently isn't it is not going to work
and we need to learn the irrelevant and
requisite lessons let me be completely
clear about this we will negotiate in a
robust way but the fundamental right to
Asylum we will never call into question
because this would betray our very
values those values which bind us
together and therefore we need to come
together to find and the solutions which
we so desperately need we need to
Vanquish populism and we need to
recognize that yes robust negotiations
are necessary but a good solution is
important more important than anything
else and this is what the s d is
committed to this is what we have
consistently said and we will support
people who need our help in time of need
thank you the next speaker
is Malik Osmani
well they are presidents their
Commissioners in us their Secretary of
State let me start by congratulating
congratulating youth Secretary of State
because finally at the justice and home
Affairs meeting last week we saw a
glimmer of hope
and let's hope also that corporate this
morning will succeed
hope for a real progress on the
migration and Asylum pact thinking ahead
to the informal Summit in Granada when
Europe wants this hope to be turned into
results because there is no doubt to
adopt this migration pact this mandate
we need an agreement before the end of
this year
and we need to be realistic to get this
package over the line a tremendous
amount of work still needs to be done
this will require a constructive
approach also in this house and here
their colleagues are remind us all that
we have a big responsibility in doing so
because agreement can only come from the
political Center in this house
let it be a broad majority that deliver
real European solutions to the
challenges of our time
as we did for covet
as we continue to do for Ukraine
and we cannot reward those who spread
fear about migration for electoral
reasons but vote against your actions
again and again
managing migration in a proper way is
not easy it requires actions on all
sides including the external dimension
we need to engage with certain countries
to address the root causes of migration
and provide the sustability in the
neighborhood
and we know the building blocks
fight the migrant smuggling Networks
solve the root causes of irregular
migration
more legal Pathways and truly effective
readmission and return policy
of course our agreement with Third
Country should not only consider
stopping a regular migration but they
should be about investing in a long-term
broad partnership with our neighboring
countries and countries of origin
colleagues the last week have revolved
around our crisis response to lombarduza
and a tragic event unfolding there
a European response is needed and we
need it now
in a migration pack a crisis mechanism
is foreseen why should we wait for the
adoption of it why can we not anticipate
start for example implementing really
use support for the Border return
procedure for those who are unlikely to
be granted for exile for example and to
have some solidarity in the European
Union towards Italy their colleagues the
clock is ticking and we are already
approaching extra time together we can
manage the challenges of migration
where there is a will there is a way
thank you
the next speaker is Philip Lombard
Claude illegals clandestines migratory
flows
pull factor protecting our borders
reform our order to leave the territory
cold words
aseptic words and they still I think
confine if you like our debate on Asylum
and migration these are words that
exclude and they hide the incredible
violence that is inflicted upon people
who are seeking our protection
the reality of the situation is that
children women men are dying every day
at the borders of Europe because we
refuse to teach them treat them with
dignity people being forced to leave
their homes because of War
because of climate catastrophes none of
us none of us would like to go through
that if we were in such a situation all
of us would do exactly the same thing
each and every one of us would be Exiles
you know that
Asylum and migration are complex issues
there are no simple answers
no indeed a general opening of borders
but Fortress Europe is of course not a
viable solution either
and that is nevertheless what the EU has
been doing since 2015 with the Asylum
and migration pack that is currently on
the table for discussion we're talking
about stopping departures strengthening
our borders
sending people back to the country's
origin even if they might be failed
States or dictatorships and like I said
abuse of language
militia who are supposed to catch Exiles
and we're providing that kind of support
to the Border guards that are supposed
to save lives at sea
the question before his colleagues is
this first of all
does the EU bear some responsibility a
part of the responsibility for the
causes that Force this form of Exile as
far as we're concerned yes we do bear a
part of that responsibility and that is
why morally speaking we have to shoulder
that responsibility and that brings me
on to the second question
does the EU have the means to do this
Manfred Weber said it some member states
have already done a lot but it's not the
case for everyone collectively we could
do more we could do better and finally
does our Union have the human resources
that we need in order to meet the
challenges of the 21st century the
climate transition for instance our
conclusion is that those who are seeking
Refuge with us are not a burden no quite
the opposite they could contribute to
our overall welfare the United Kingdom
since brexit has been experiencing this
and it's been a painful experience a
genuine pact should therefore
re-establish safe routes for arrival and
a fair distribution of exilees between
member states that is the way of
breaking the business model of human
traffickers and the if the EU really
wants to address the causes for
departure then we need to revisit our
political economic and security
relations with countries of departure to
make sure that these countries are
livable countries for those who are
there dear colleagues the way in which
the EU deals with exilees at its borders
is in a way an illustration of our
flagrant denial of principles such as
human dignity look no further the main
reason why the EU has lost credibility
in the global South and in Africa in
particular is because of this so rather
than indifference Pope Francis in fact
spoke out about this indifference let us
return to our duty of civilization and
Humanity instead thank you
thank you
Nicola procaccini
thank you very much president
commissioner colleagues
reforming the European rules on
immigration and Asylum is absolutely
correct it is urgent and it is very
important but how do we do this on the
one hand obviously we do need to take in
people who are feeling war and
persecution on the other hand we also
have a duty to deal with illegal
immigration the Red Gold tainted with
blood which is greedily sought by the
human traffickers is based on sexual
crime on terrorism
on exploitation of workers and is
rampant across our borders
illegal immigration is of course also
weaponized by those who
advocated the no borders ideology which
is also common aboard these Ong boats
and this is indeed one of the problems
which has arisen the policy of the
German government in the light of the
discussions on the migrant migration
Pact
using the taxes paid by the German
citizens
the government is simply putting money
into the pockets of those who are
operating these illegal boats this is
not a logical solution we need to
address the issues of secondary
migration to France and to Germany and
this is no way of doing it
there are some very radical theories
about migration but the reality is that
we are denying one of the things which
we achieved in history which is the free
movement of individuals and goods across
the European Union two days ago in
Frankfurt when many of us got off the
plane in
from Italy every single passenger was
checked including those who were coming
to the European Parliament and therefore
it is clear for crystal clear for all to
see that the Schengen borders are no
more the borders have been reinstated
and we have wide open borders at the
external borders but borders in the
center of the European Union this is not
the way to tackle illegal immigration
until such time as we can we will never
be able to deal with legal immigration
and we need to of course provide for
that but the external agreements which
we are engaged in negotiating have got
to be based on proper policing and
monitoring of our borders got to be
based on sensible thinking and
abandoning this new hopes barred utopian
vision of the last century thank you
sunny
the next speaker
thank you very much president today we
commemorated the anniversary the you
said anniversary of the tragedy in
lampedusa we commemorated the loss of
life which took place on that occasion
in that in the number of people who were
drowned there but here we are today
talking about what have we achieved to
try to tackle this problem in the last
10 years the answer is clear to see all
around we've done absolutely nothing
we've achieved absolutely nothing we
haven't managed to reduce the number of
people coming to their deaths in the
Mediterranean on the contrary the
national institutions the supranational
institutions have failed ngos have
failed even the courts have failed
Mateo salvini is the Minister of the
home Affairs in Italy and it's Lottery
that said this it's also borne out by
the UN agency figures as he said you can
go and look it all up you can see 2015
in Italy 150
000 people arrive 3 000 people loss of
died 2016 over 180 000 people around 4
000 people died in 2017 120 000 to 3 000
people died this was all under the
governed thing
socialists what has happened more
recently Representatives have elected
institutions have established a number
of principles which should be
self-evident in Italy but also in Europe
more widely you can only come in Legally
in 2018 we saw a reduction 23 000 a
thousand people died in 2019 the number
of deaths fell and the number of
arrivals filled we actually reached the
lowest point and we seem to be achieving
something resembling protection of our
external borders however
since then the numbers have climbed very
rapidly and
at the end of all these numbers and data
what I'd like to ask you is a question
who has actually contributed to reducing
any
any deaths the numbers are quite clear
we haven't done enough and this shows
quite clearly that we've got to find
some solutions and we've got to find a
way to stop people leaving the countries
that are coming from and we've got to
find a way to stop these deaths in the
Mediterranean thank you
Aubry
thank you president
colleagues I listened carefully
to especially to that side of the
chamber one thing struck me there
you talk about migration
the reason
gives place to some hysteria the uh
Nightmares of the right about
migration gives way to another reality
we didn't have an invasion in lampedusa
but 12 000 men women and children
fleeing misery and War
and are now in in
um
terrible conditions we we shouldn't
it's when you get onto one of these
boats it's not like getting on a cruise
ship
it's 0.03 of the European population so
the migration Invasion it's a fable the
that's the far right is whipping up for
to make people afraid
colleagues on the far right Mr Sunny Mr
bardella
uh the big this lie this wolf doesn't
exist
four million people ukrainians of
fleeing War but we're not capable of uh
taking on 12
000 migration migrants is it their their
skin color or their religion that
bothers you commissioner the EU is
responsible for the chaos in Lamb
producer wished by the uh the far route
and put in place by the Liberals you've
shut down uh reception centers you've
criminalized Energies
um
sidelined the fundamental rights
signed shameful agreements with
countries like
uh like Tunisia which let people drown
and die of thirst
you've created
tragic conditions which have been
repeated year after year in the south of
Europe the
crisis regulation
uh shuts our eyes to the violation of
fundamental rights of refugees it's
always the same rapid Refugee recipes
more broken lives if your objectives to
limit migratory flows the politic policy
policy is not efficiency how many more
deaths in the Mediterranean do we have
to see before you understand that your
policies are not working
as we keep saying we need to have a
reception policy which protects rights
we need to protect ngos
and have proper s and r
we need to show solidarity rather than
the approach that you are in favor of
for the non-attached
I give the floor to Laura Ferrara
Presidente
thank you very much president
three years on and eight years from the
very beginning of these discussions on
the migration pact we still haven't seen
the light of day and it is countries
like the like Italy and the
Mediterranean that's paying the price
for all this delay and failure let me
remind you once again lampedusa is
Italian yes but it's also a border of
the European Union and it is a Land of
Hope for
migrants refugees who have escaped from
war starvation and the climate crisis
and what are we doing to mitigate their
plight nothing we are exacerbating it we
need to have a proper piece of European
legislation based on Good Sense on
providing legal means of entering the
European Union we are absolutely Fed Up
of having to
countenance these deaths in the
Mediterranean 26 000 over the last few
years and we need to have a shared
responsibility at long last we need to
show through facts and action that we're
stronger than extremism and nationalism
thank you speak guys Mr Sharon
yes thank you president uh the aquatics
in 2016 the junker commission presented
its proposals for a better EU Asylum and
migration policy learning the lessons of
the 2015 Refugee crisis and ever since
that moment we have been waiting waiting
for the day that member states would
finally find an agreement so we can do
what our voters expect from us managing
migration in a better way and we request
that this debate this morning to put the
pressure on member States ambassadors
meeting this morning have to urgently
find an agreement on the last remaining
part of The Pact the crisis regulation
they must deliver today because only
then
will we have a window of opportunity to
really make an impact and even that
window will not be open forever we
cannot afford to lose any more time we
have to conclude this now whatever it
takes because we need this fact we need
it to rebuild trust among Our member
states to move from ad hoc individual
responses to an eu-wide permanent
solution based on solidarity and we need
it because Fair sharing of
responsibility will only happen when we
have our European house in order we need
to strengthen our external borders fight
people Smugglers and the
instrumentalization of migrations and we
need more effective returns
and we need this part this packed mostly
also to regain the trust of our citizens
and to show them that we are capable of
managing migration in a responsible Way
by finding Solutions in the center
instead of leaving the narrative to the
open border shelters on the extreme left
or the zero migration shelters on the
extreme right and I would like to thank
vice president skinas for his Relentless
efforts in trying to break the deadlock
and find a reasonable Landing zone for
almost all member states his pact will
prove to be a historic breakthrough in
one of the most sensitive policy areas
in the EU but we first need to make it
happen and the Epp is committed to
constructively playing its role and get
this done you can count on us thank you
thank you
Mr Pedro Marcus
thank you Mr President dear vice
president chenus it is indeed a Timeless
debate this one just two days ago
president Syed said it doesn't need our
charity
you see Mr Vice President exporting the
migration challenges faces this nasty
reality particularly if you think of
paying an authoritarian regime a few
billions will do the trick I can even
imagine president Syed Furious thinking
so I was doing them a favor and now they
want to come here and see how well treat
the migrants no way
the problem commissioner and Mr Fever by
the way is that they don't even want to
ask to have a glimpse on what they do
with our money they just continue with
their policies with no regard for human
rights in the meantime people did not
stop coming stranded in dangerous
vessels through the summer while we were
already supposedly dealing with
implementation of the memorandum we have
to address migration in a completely
different way what we need is solidarity
with the refugees but also with those
member states particularly Italy where
they arrive in Europe and with the
communities where they are finally
hosted it is obvious we need to manage
migration at our borders handling the
situation of the illegal arrivals but
certainly it doesn't have to be done in
a year a new main way
so commissioner and Mr Weber let us
refocus our energies on The Pact on
migration show real solidarity towards
the Frontline countries step up our
capacities at the Mediterranean to
arrest the Smugglers increase the search
and rescue capacity of this Europe and
support the refugee Seekers and let's
not forget to put a priority into
working with the origin and Transit
countries we have global gateway let us
make it count and build true
Partnerships for development where the
populists want us to fail let's go
Humane thank you
thank you
thank you very much the next speaker is
Sofia Mr Minister Mr commissioner it has
been said by many that the clock is
ticking we owe it to the citizens of
Europe to finally adopt a proper Asylum
and migration policy and so we are
eagerly awaiting the position of the
Council on the crisis regulation which
is the key to the rest of the package
but
I warn you that's not the end of the
process because a negotiating mandate
should leave sufficient margin for
negotiations and compromise with the
European Parliament it cannot be rigid
it's the start of negotiations between
the two legislators I hear many people
talk about realism
realism means working seriously on the
internal dimension of migration policies
a proper common European Asylum and
migration policy that includes not just
mandatory solidarity but mandatory
relocation because only that is real
solidarity
the famous
blueprint Tunisia deal turns out not to
be a blueprint but a fob a blueprint of
how not to do it because a deal that
props up a dictator that leads to
massive human rights violations and
deaths a deal that is not enforceable
and that has done absolutely nothing to
reduce the number of variety of Rivals
is not a blueprint but only a group
blueprint for how not to do it it's high
time after so many years that the member
states take their responsibility this
house is ready thank you
thank you Mr Charlie Soleil employees
president
thank you very much present we have been
debating for years how to go about
adopting a common Asylum migration
policy
and this is one of the most polarized
topics for debate that we've ever had
partly because of populism probably
because the extreme right weaponizes
this whole topic and partly because
there is urgency right across the board
to adopt the package
the current Arrangements obviously are a
complete failure in terms of Human
Rights lives lost
and suffering on our external borders we
have not shown enough responsibility as
individual governments and ngos are
simply being put in the dock for having
rescued
migrants from sea we need to make
progress and we need to have proper
negotiations based on solidarity we need
legal means of access Asylum and
migration should be part of
international law founded on human
rights which must be fully respected in
cooperation with third countries and on
our borders all these issues in the area
of migration have to be based on a
response founded on human dignity we've
got to improve our
absorption
rates throughout our society we have to
be able to have proper reception centers
and proper resettlement thank you
thank you the next speaker speaker is
foreign
commissioner ladies and gentlemen
The Proposal of the European commission
included and the migration pact will
they protect Europe against illegal
migrants will they guarantee security
for Europeans no these are not good
Solutions
I heard a similar proposals in 2016 when
I was the prime minister of Poland after
the crisis
that was due to an invitation by Germany
extended towards illegal migrants we had
to seek for solutions to protect
Europeans and Europe against illegal
migration
these solutions back then were not the
good ones and now after yes we are back
at square one yet another migration
crisis thousands of illegal migrants who
end up in Europe
human Smugglers human trafficking
ngos from Germany which Finance these
kinds of actions we need to block it we
need to say no and Poland wants to find
this kind of solutions that will help
these people who really need help we
want to help people who suffer who flee
from war
Poland has taken refugees from Ukraine
and we have proven that it is possible
but I want it to be clear Poland will
never agree to admit illegal migrants we
will never agree to the relocation we
will never agree to this absurd fees for
people being relocated thank you madam
do you accept it
do you accept the blue card
for Mr kohut
yes
okay Mr code
please stop saying these kind of things
because this is a serious problem that
the whole of Europe has been facing you
use it as political fuel seven days a
week you are doing this kind of thing
why didn't you get additional money from
the EU for Ukrainian migrants are you
that incompetent or is that your policy
that you want to really use these
migrants to win elections is this a
Christian approach and in the meantime
you've been selling polish visas because
uh this is just simply not fair
foreign
ladies and gentlemen
I do respect the decision-making process
in the European Parliament so I will not
conduct an electoral campaign right now
because this is what my colleague has
been attempting to do
let me reiterate Poland is for the
security of Europeans and Europe we will
protect Poland our next speaker is Mr
Jordan padella
Mercy Museum
thank you very much president dear
colleagues
lampedusa
that tragic situation is our future if
we don't take back control of our
borders in France and elsewhere
from The Lion encourage member states to
welcome these persons from lamparduza
Over the even though they don't meet
Asylum requirements
remember the principle of nobra full
Mall European judges have actually
instituted a pull factor and are
encouraging so many people to come to
Europe look at frontex it's not actually
a Border guard it's actually now acting
as some kind of reception facility there
is no alternative to being firm standing
firm means protecting the people of
Europe against a brutal World Mass
migration leads to cultural devastation
and indeed social consequences
therefore being firm standing firm is
deterring people from Crossing avoiding
human tragedy
we cannot actually unconditionally
welcome everyone in Europe it cannot be
done because of course Europe will never
be a territory that belongs to anyone
everyone without a history this is the
land of our history of our Europeans and
we are the ones who decide who may enter
the only ones who can decide what we
want we want to be in the 21st century
what we intend to be thank you
[Applause]
East
the next speaker is malinberg
friends colleagues a speedy adoption of
the package
but of what package what policies
from our side in the left in in
partnership with citizens and
organization across and movements across
Europe we have consistently asked for
European policy where we have a shared
responsibility between the member states
to receive people we have a reception
with dignity where we save lives in the
Mediterranean and where we cooperate
with third countries in order to propose
propose democracy peace economic and
social development and human rights and
the way negotiations are going is the
very opposite
the European Union is making deals with
authoritarian leaders beat erdogan or in
turkey or Indonesia
you want to see and you're negotiating
currently a system built on systematic
detention at Borders and return to any
country even a safe third country where
people just pass by
this is and we have a system of
systematic violence at the EU borders
this is what happens when the center
right give in to the extreme right
racist narrative a racist and
authoritarian narrative it is very
dangerous
we know that we can do differently we
have seen it with the reception of
Ukrainian refugees thankfully we have
seen that fleeing putins bombs and his
War we have seen solidarity between
member states we have seen dignified
reception conditions so we know it can
be done now we also have to replicate
and do the right thing when it comes to
all refugees seeking seeking protection
in Europe from other Wars from other
conflicts this pact is not our Pact
papatakis
we will not allow
the crime of police will be forgotten we
seek answers at the Greek government the
EU and Frances are not providing the
meetings of EU ministers as well as
ahmed9
affirmed the common understanding to
reinforce repression and a triage system
for refugees according to capitalist
needs
therefore we see that the Greek and
Turkish governments are planning a new
joint statement that will reactivate
deportations they will reinforce
prosecution and repression to the
detriment of people fleeing imperialist
Wars which are compounded by the
terrible situation we see today in the
Aegean where people are drowning they're
being pushed back and there are human
traffickers active there is a bargaining
going on on this agreement against the
backdrop of imperialist competition this
is why Greek and other workers needed to
have a joint fight against the EU and
the capital and the government
he was
and uh senior secretary
Secretary of State
vice president
Asylum and
migration policy requires a reform
urgently
I support the commission and vice
president skeenus in his efforts to
reach an agreement in 2023
so that from 2024 after the elections in
particular we have a Asylum and
migration Pact
in
Europe that can be implemented to
achieve that it is essential
to be aware that our policy must be
designed based on fundamental rights and
human dignity fundamental rights of
migrants whether they're legal or
illegal but
but all European citizens must be taken
into account so we're in favor of
strict
controls against on the external borders
we must act against the these Smugglers
and traffickers who exploit people's
misery and if there are migrants in an
illegal situation they must be
securely and properly sent back we
shouldn't forget that it's important to
have agreements with third countries and
we need
dialogue platforms
so that illegal migrants can be sent
back and we need a development Aid to
ensure that these flows aren't necessary
the Epps is very clear on this only if
we can protect our external borders only
then can we maintain human rights we
don't want what
to see what happens in Lisbon there are
flats with 20 people living in them
these are not human rights
to handle um humanized properly we
should take those who have a right to
come here all migrants or Asylum Seekers
have the right to migration
and reception but we can control who has
the right to come in and who doesn't
foreign foreign
thank you very much president
Minister colleagues yesterday we
commemorated the 10th anniversary of the
tragedy of lampedusa and sadly all too
many subsequent tragedies have occurred
and on each occasion one pauses to Usman
so forth where is Europe This is not
Europe and yet this seems to be what it
is this is not what the European
Parliament is trying to do in its work
we've been demanding a proper framework
for search and rescue for migration
we've been trying to adopt all our
negotiating framework on all the
migration package reports because we
feel there is a strong sense of shared
responsibility and we need effective
legislation to cover for example
reception and search and rescue and we
need to implement the Mandate from
Lisbon this Parliament has worked long
and hard to overcome differences across
the groups the council needs to do the
same come together and resolve your
differences of opinion it's high time
the council thought about something more
than conflicting contradictory national
interests think about the Europeans
think about the principle of solidarity
think about solidarity for the migrants
the Spanish presidency please you need
to have a successful conclusion on this
migration package by the end of your
presidency otherwise it will be not just
discouraging it will be absolutely
disastrous and a destruction for Europe
it will be a failure to fulfill our
promises it will be a destruction of PRI
our primary legal responsibilities which
are one of the founding pillars of our
original debt as an institution thank
you
thank you
Madame Fabian killer
seven killer this president
's president odma minister
if we want to have the European pact on
Asylum and migration before the
elections
difficult decisions
have to be taken now colleagues it's a
Moment of Truth for member states first
of all we are looking forward to the
council positions as you said on the
crisis regulation this text is one of
the cornerstones of The Pact
couldn't we imagine a credible reform
with a
crisis management mechanism
what that's what we have to say to the
inhabitants of
lampedusa it's a Moment of Truth for the
European Parliament between those who
want to have a real European response to
the challenges of migration
with responsibility and boldness and
those who want nothing
and who want to make these negotiations
failed I'm shocked by the attitude of
the far right
and in front of the cameras to spread
Horrors
in fact the far right is not
working on the issue Mr bardella and Mrs
zemur are absent they're absent from the
negotiations where important decisions
are being taken with my group renew
we are determined
to conclude this important reform we are
ready
to take our responsibilities thank you
very much
merci
thank you very much chair Council
commissioner
Asylum Seekers face an Ever more Lawless
Europe
a Europe of pushbacks inhuman reception
conditions unlawful detention becoming
the new normal but make no mistake this
is not due to a lack of EU legislation
it's a result of unequal responsibility
sharing and total impunity for the
member states so yes we need a new pact
but one rooted in solidarity one that
harmonizes standards of protection and
is coupled with credible enforcement
and the current packed positions of a
remix back mandatory relocation is
promising but border procedures and
increase their locations will only
undermine the harmonized protection that
we mean to achieve
so our urge Council and Parliament to
focus on actually strengthening the
system through real solidarity and a
truly common framework and I urge the
commission to show us that our lawmaking
is not in vain
and that any current and future laws are
finally enforced thank you
Mercy miss your chat
thank you very much
thank you uh Mr President
colleagues
do you really want to fix this migration
crisis
you commissioner schemas you say it out
loud The Pact is intended to deprive the
demagogues and populists in Europe from
campaigning on migration in the EU
elections commissioner
are you even aware what's going on in
Sweden ordinary men and women face the
consequences of a migration policy that
spawned the monster that is gang
violence where's your pact for the 25
year old girl blown up by gangsters or
the 71 year old shot in the pub while
having a pint your job Mr skinas I'm
sorry but it's not to be campaign
manager for the left it's to deal with
illegal migration so do your job and
inform us on how we escort the boats
back to their ports otherwise the low
intensive war on the Swedish streets as
the police puts it as the police puts it
will worsen you laugh
left to the 17 innocent victims shot to
death bombed to death in Sweden shame on
you
you know
as well
thank you sir
Madison
thanks so much dear collection
commissioner
Minister and I'm just spending 10
seconds to just announce for the
president it's very polite of course for
the leftists to laugh about the murders
and the killings what's going on in
Sweden because you don't care about that
yourself is overpaid bureaucrats who
have tried to force your migration
policy in last four years and you have
failed you absolutely failed we see that
in left left wing governments in the
Western Europe
so that's why you have no Alternatives
you're just talking about the free open
borders helping the people but where's
the limit
is the sky only the limit how much does
it cost what's going on with the
security of the streets are you also
ready to send your kids alone to play
outside no
because that's your fault still in
Poland or in Estonia I don't have to
worry about my kids
but our alternative makes sense just
look about your own socialist College in
Denmark they just had an agreement with
Rwanda to have hot spots out from the
Europe and then we're going to choose
who are real refugees and who are
illegal migrants the fact is I was last
week in lampetusa that 90 of the
migrants are young men and they're
illegals they are not refugees and you
are lying to our own people we are the
only ones who love Europe and our own
people to protect them thank you
thank you
thank you very much
Mr Madison
do you accept the blue card
yes
the efforts of the Danish government in
Rwanda the efforts of the Danish
governments are pies in the sky Castles
in the Sky they're not actually coming
to anything Rwanda does not respect
human rights how can you propose that we
want to send refugees Asylum Seekers to
Rwanda and your claims that they are
that they are undocumented refugees that
they do not have rights to seek safety
in Europe where are your facts on this
and I would wish that you base your
statements in this Hall of plenary on
facts and not loose ideas
that's actually very good that you're
pointing about the facts because very
often we are hearing here about the
false claims that most of them are just
young women and kids that's that's not
the fact I was last week meeting with a
Red Cross organization in lampadusa
we're asking the facts and please tell
me honestly who they are just do you
have the numbers how many have a right
64 000 people this year I write only the
LA producer huge majority of them about
85 90 were men that's the fact about
Denmark yes uh
it has to be make work and that's also
your work because what is the solution
what is alternative just open the
borders take them in and turn 40 of the
illegals are not sent back because you
don't have capable for that so your
solution is pretty bad
thank you very much
the next speaker is Vice President
let's be honest
colleagues
we do need a common European policy of
Asylum and migration but in order to
achieve that
we need a lot less hypocrisy and true
solidarity between member states
a true practical solidarity towards the
countries of reception that are under
immense pressure like my country Greece
and a distribution of responsibilities
between member states for
obligatory mandatory relocation
a true system that will put an end to
the loss of human lives through policies
of um of integration that will boost our
societies and our economies and a true
respect of humanitarian rights and the
international
um
commitments of the EU
we have heard a lot of grandstanding of
the far right that is trying to utilize
the migration and Refugee crisis that
once because they want to undermine the
United Europe and representative
democracy we should not allow this until
the end of the year we must
come to this pact to agree upon this
pact the council the Spanish presidency
should do their part as well as the
European Parliament thank you
thank you very much
hit record
I think the president uh your colleagues
besides lampedusa some of the latest
news about migration in Europe the
Swedish government is now talking about
the deployment of the Army against
criminal gangs of migrants because the
police are no longer enough to handle
the situation and maintain order and
protect citizens
illegal migrants have used Firearms
against Hungarian and Croatian border
guards recently
the Schengen zone is in critical danger
because of illegal migration more and
more internal border controls are
reinstated because of it meanwhile the
German government is happily admitted
that it funds organizations that tacitly
cooperate with criminal gangs of human
Smugglers and then transport these
people into Italy now just to make it
clear migration is destroying the
European way of life it creates
insecurity for our citizens and it must
be stopped now some of you may be
multiculturalism Maniacs despite all the
clear evidence against it that's your
problem but we're never going to let
that happen to our countries we Central
Europeans did not join the European
Union to now endanger our freedom of
movement to now endanger our culture and
the security of our Citizens We're going
to defend our way of life we're going to
protect our countries our people and our
culture thank you very much
thank you our next speaker is Mr Thomas
yours
thank you your president
migration crisis after migration crisis
the situation in lampadusa shows this
again
and colleagues we really are at a
crossroad now
either we continue down this road where
member states act independently
we try to meet the situation with ad hoc
solution
or we build common European Solutions
and actions where we can have control of
the borders
where we can make a bigger difference
between people who have the right to
protection in Europe and irregular
migrants
and when we work with cooperation
in Europe and with third countries we
cannot have this situation where only a
few member states shall bear the big
responsibility of the immigration policy
and I really would like to to urge
colleagues we have an opportunity to
really do something
and of course I put my trust in the
center right but I would also like to
acknowledge that parts of the ECR group
also voted in favor of going into
negotiations and I welcome that because
I really think that we need to make sure
that we have a broad support for the new
migration policy
with the migration pact hopefully
adopted of course we also need to do
more about the Smugglers we cannot have
a situation where this Smugglers who
actually decide who has the right to
enter European territory
and in my book you need cooperation with
third countries of course not easy with
Tunisia of course not even easy with
turkey but what is the alternative
the Epp group is here to deliver
to again build trust amongst our
citizens and make sure that we have a
European migration policy that actually
works thank you
thank you
foreign
in the months ahead we could conclude
the work that's been going on for years
on the reform of us Asylum we're working
on that intensively it's necessary
because how this reform will actually
look the positions of Parliament and
Council are very different my Social
Democratic group
is prepared for difficult negotiations
from the Epp seems to see that
differently
the position of the parliament
he's ignoring that and he simply wants
to wave through the council position and
evidently many member states see that in
the same way
and like Mr Weber they see it they show
a Shabby understanding of the
significance of parliament as an equal
co-legislator and a lack of democratic
understanding
none of the two institutions can decide
the migration package itself both must
make compromises the preparedness of
that is
lacking on the side of some member
states and also Mr Weber
migration is a challenge and also an
opportunity the tasks associated with
that are manifold
and an agreement on Asylum could be a
solid Cornerstone alongside an asylum
package we knew rules for labor
migration a more intensive cooperation
with local authorities and countries of
origin and also target targeted support
so there are good perspectives for our
citizens and for refugees we have an
opportunity
let's take it thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much
the next speaker is Mr young Christopher
thank you very much president colleagues
2015 was the year of the major migration
crisis in the EU here eight years later
we are engaged in the self-same debate
colleagues the citizens of Europe don't
understand why politics takes so long to
catch up with events and to find
solutions to problems we owe them a
response and we really owe it to the
citizens to make progress to deliver a
solution before the elections and we are
not that far off the mark
on the other hand it has to be said it's
unacceptable that the crisis regulation
is simply being held hostage for a
political gameplay and this is coming of
course from the right of the political
Spectrum this is simply not acceptable
it is not acceptable to block
negotiations on a package
on the migration package in particular
because of self-seeking
aspirations there is far too much at
stake the danger is too great that we
fail on this whole migration package and
this absolutely must not happen we
therefore need to ask to act quickly we
need to ensure that the council takes
the requisite action very quickly and
that the member states implement the
agreements which we have reached we will
have to get control of the migration
issue we've got to have much better and
more Humane standards on our borders and
we've got to have a proper crisis
management system worth a name thank you
take my crap
thank you very much
what I'm worried about that I get the
impression that in the debate about the
impact many member states think that
refugees must be treated worse than
today every day treat them a little bit
worse than yesterday and then at some
point that stopped coming
it's so cynical that we're discussing
whether the people should say people at
sea it's not the question of people are
in need at see the question is they
should be saved and let them drown drown
and
um
so that others wouldn't be trafficked if
we think that this
this policy doesn't lead Justice to
misery it doesn't work people are being
uh scared off but they're still coming
we forget that humanity and the rule of
law aren't just uh
add-ons to our democracy their
cornerstones of it's the Cornerstone of
what constitutes Europe I think if
member states want to be successful
it'll be important that they show trust
amongst their population and many things
in the impact that we're talking about
now it's happening already the share
distribution uh
Fair distribution in the labor market we
could improve things and have legal
rather than illegal Market migration
that because it's not happening it's not
because we don't have a pact because
there's a lack of political will and I'd
like us to start with that now and
continue to negotiate afterwards thank
you very much please
gracias Presidente thank you very much
president it's hypocritical to organize
a debate on the urgency of this pact
uradak for instance has been paralyzed
because this Parliament is blackmailing
the member states we have a permanent
emergency because of mass migration
thousands of illegal migrants arriving
in the canaries over just two days
there's violence
and very soon they'll be in fact at the
airport in Madrid and they can go
anywhere in Europe they come in here to
get benefits benefits which are paid for
by the working and middle classes of
Europeans but not in order to contribute
it's not just lamp producer the whole of
Europe is in the hands of the mafia this
is a multi-billion business
is a form of trade we're talking about
human rights we're talking about false
refugees but you know that's not saving
lives in Mediterranean or elsewhere
we're supposed to feel guilty but you
are the guilty party and history will
show that
no Europeans
will be
vanquished in this way we're not going
to give up our freedom our streets our
families we will not
be defeated if we don't defend our
borders we will have to defend our
streets and otherwise we will be simply
confined to our homes and that is not
the way forward thank you speaker is Mr
Tom van Risha please
colleagues Asylum law is being exploited
as a channel for illegal immigration
into Europe
total Asylum chaos is the name of the
day everybody is aware of the problem
but nobody will resolve it nobody is
able to act and indeed it seems to be
ourselves fulfilling prophecy which all
parties involved want to continue
actually the European Union wants more
migration
they simply want to turn illegal
migration into legal migration so that
millions of Africans every single year
can come into Europe legally because
after all migration is necessary as
commissioner Johansson has said we don't
have enough
births in Europe the birthright is too
low and commissioner eurova has also
said this so the colonization of Europe
and the subjugation of the Europeans the
destruction indeed the suicide of our
unique culture is what we Face through
this migration pact which is an absolute
scandal
please
president commissioner
Secretary of State
at this point I don't think we can doubt
anymore that this migration pact is
actually a monstrosity and it has been
made tailor-made for the far right
just where we thought that nothing could
surprise us anymore well Along Comes
baloney and asks for a just a little bit
more namely criminalizing
rescue ngos for years and years we've
been listening to a narrative that
dehumides humanizes sorry migrants maybe
that makes it more tolerable to accept
that these people drown at sea or that
they're returned to a desert or that
they are tortured in places like Libya
Mr skinas I Turn to You all of this
suffering is actually being paid for by
our money we are allocating more and
more resources to militarize our borders
to externalize our borders and all of
this will be locked down in the new pact
I think you're hiding the fact that the
Asylum procedure has been turned into a
labyrinth from which There Is No Escape
you can't actually meet these
requirements to access your rights and
this is not about Outsiders it's
actually about an attack an attack on
our whole system of rights that give
Europe it's very meaning thank you Mr
Evan villibels inchich please
[Applause]
the cause of migration are centuries of
exploitation of African and Asian
countries by European colonizers who
went to search the resources for the for
the industry also we have now
indeedness
and World economists say they
uh that Africa has been robbed for three
decades of development by debt in my
country Croatia in Carlo that's we have
many incidents
because we have a large groups of
migrants that
citizens do not feel safe with on the
streets illegal migrants can cross
borders without the legal documents and
we cannot cross borders without
documents
borders have to be in order we need our
army to prevent uh entry into our
countries to those who do not have the
right to enter
Croatia is a safe country and needs to
remain safe we do not want another
Sweden please
dear colleagues
I will speak Lithuanian
we cannot ignore a new form of hybrid
Warfare the instrumentalized migration
where dictators use migration as a
weapon we must make this clear in the EU
documents
states that border unpredictable regimes
such as Belarus and Russia must have the
tools to respond effectively to their
instrumentalization of migrants
at let me uh thank the commission and
The Honorable commissioner for your help
when lukashenga attacked my country why
do that dictators organize hybrid
attacks against EU countries well
because they know all the loopholes in
our legal system and our external
borders and therefore they are able to
cause chaos they use misled people as a
weapon against us
by failing to protect our borders we
contribute to the smug glass business
and help dictators to initiate attacks I
therefore find it very strange that the
Socialists and other leftists in the
labor committee have removed the
commission's proposal on the
instrumentalization of migration from
the schengen's border act this must be
brought back the epist position and the
dialogue cannot be to present this act
without important Provisions to protect
the external borders from deliberately
organized attacks against us we must fix
the loop codes in the EU legal framework
I call on my colleagues tomorrow to do
so the urgency to launch a trial lock
must not be at the expense of the
quality of their document and I ask the
colleagues to return this into the
document
thank you
grazia Presidente thank you very much
president
is
three years now that we have been
working on the legislative proposals in
this pact and we have played our full
part as co-legislators we have worked on
compromises across the political
spectrum and we have distilled from a
lot of disparate ideas a lot of
constructive work the commissions talked
about firefighting and about the
architects of a future policy but what
have we actually achieved so far so far
of course the council is still trapped
in disagreement and there are some
absurd suggestions from countries such
as Italy where there seems to be some
kind of informal bilateral agreement
based on some perception of the policy
implications which is actually
contributing nothing to finding uh
legitimate and properly constructed pact
and solution which will finally help us
to treat migration as
a necessity and the policy
because to be constructed on a more
Humane basis we have got to treat people
properly we've got to learn from them
producer we've got to make it possible
to have integration and we've got to
practice policy on the basis of
solidarity thank you speaker SMS hildew
about months please
foreign
thank you very much
president 10 years after lampedusa it's
extremely painful to observe the
complete dearth of proper policy in the
area of migration we've got more border
controls internally we've got women and
children being drowned at sea
coming to land after a traumatic Journey
we've got millions of applicants for
Asylum who've simply gone missing and
many many people who have gone missing
during their tragic Journey
across the sea it's absolutely painful
to see that we've got no deal in place
we've got no proper pact that will
actually address any of these issues
I've heard a million suggestions all
sorts of things from the left under
utter Observer absurdities from the
right side of the house but it is our
duty to protect children at the very
least there are ten thousand children
this year alone who have gone missing
either on the way here or on our
continent children are always the
victims in migration and we have
absolutely got to do something to
address this issue immediately thank you
okay dear colleagues I missed sorry I
missed the blue card from Miss Sophie
infal to Mr van derision Mr van derision
do you accept that blue card
there was a blue cut which I missed for
you from Mrs Sophie infelt would you
accept that blue card
okay
so please come here and then I give the
floor to miss Sophie van infeld and I
apologize for having missed this thank
you please yes chair maybe actually I
should address the question to you
because I've had this exchange with Mr
van derisa many times he's using a term
which is a Nazi term and he knows that
full well and I would like to ask you Mr
chair rather than Mr van derision
whether the use of Nazi terminology in
this hemicycle is acceptable he uses the
term unfolding which is the the Dutch
version of um which is a Nazi term do we
accept that in this hemicycle chair I
would really like an answer to that I've
had the exchange with Mr Van de Teresa
many times in the Libya committee he
does it on purpose he knows it's Nazi
terminology and yet he continues to use
it
I guess the question was addressed to
myself as a chair today of course we do
not accept Nazi terminology in this
house I will report this to the bureau
and we will discuss it with the
president and with my colleagues in the
bureau thank you very much for this and
I think the question was not addressed
to you but to myself but you can you
have a 30 seconds to respond thank you
thank you president
I know that it's difficult for liberals
to recognize the need for freedom of
expression now I realize Ms interfelt
what your position is but I am entitled
to use my right to freedom of expression
and it is only right and proper that I
be given this opportunity I am as
entitled to take the floor as you and in
terms of unforking it is simply a
replacement for migration
because what is going to happen is that
our people is going to simply be
conquered by these people coming to the
community not to use freedom of
expression I will report this to the
bureau and we will we will come back to
this thank you very much now I give the
floor to Mr Karen davu
thank you president
yesterday we celebrated a sad
anniversary that of the
lamp producer tragedy the third of
um October 20 30 13 the death of 400
people led to European solidarity and
putting in place the marrow nostrum
policy that was 10 years ago we don't
have Manus nostrom anymore frontex is in
charge of external borders and
participates in illegal reform
commissioner you said that Europe is the
champion of Human Rights
the UN said that Europe with its
agreement in Libya is participating in a
crime against humanity
SNR relies on semen and ngos who are
criminalized 10 years of a bloody
policy and ten thousands dead in the
mediter
Mediterranean we've had a demolition
dismantlement of our system of reception
and
depriving people of freedoms and attacks
from the farm right the need for reform
has never been so urgent it's urgent to
to tell the council commission and the
Parliament that they have a
responsibility
we need to swiftly adopt the
assignment migration pact and this
reform this is
uh is not based on research and we're
denying people their basic rights let's
um grasp the nettle and we should
continue to negotiate with the council
and it will Define the unconditional
respect of fundamental rights and human
rights colleagues respect your speaking
terms we have a very long list and it
wouldn't be fair if not everybody can
speak in this very important debate so
miss kanku you have the floor
I had a friend
who said that we should always be asking
ourselves the right questions he himself
was always asking himself questions he
was extremely knowledgeable but he
thought that life was a school a
learning opportunity and any
conversation was a learning opportunity
and a time to
progress your own thinking my question
to my colleagues is why has it taken 20
years to fail to come up with a solution
to the tragedy of Death At Sea a
solution which would actually restore
faith in politics on the part of our
citizens I've heard a great deal of
criticism criticism against our your
colleagues criticism against the member
states which don't want to have any
Asylum Seekers and don't want to
relocate them but colleagues you're
overlooking the most important thing
which is that we need to restore
proper controls at our borders we need
to get a grip on illegal migration flows
and therefore we are going to have to
take difficult decisions we're going to
have to do deals with the countries of
origin and the ones with which we can
cooperate to impose more stringent
border controls this is absolutely
imperative we've got to get a grip of
the flows of migration coming into the
EU and then we've got to look at how we
deal with them and integration thank you
European the Asylum policy is a disaster
year after year hundreds of thousands of
illegal migrants come to Europe
completely uncontrolled two simple facts
by 2050 there'll be a billion more
people in Africa opinion polls show that
50 want to of young people want to
migrate to Europe so the pressure of
migration is a permanent State of
Affairs what is the answer from the EU
nothing
let's give migrants more rights let's
open up for more legal migration from
Africa and Asia
let
let's make agreements with undemocratic
dictatorships the only realistic and
right response to the challenge is a
permanent model where a migrant that if
you come to Europe you'll never come in
you'll be rejected you'll be put in an
asylum Center in a third country it's
effective it's worthy it prevents
criminal networks and it prevents
illegal migration this is the solution
but nobody here nobody in the commission
nobody in the council is seriously
working on that
thank you
foreign
colleagues
regarding this issue of immigration
we don't on the one hand have the good
and on the other the bad
we don't on the one hand have kind good
people and then on the other evil bad
people we don't have right extreme right
extreme left no there's a question here
one question
those who are abusing our charity
are they moved by pity Compassion or are
they moved by profit profitability
and making money out of our sentiments
today in Le Figaro newspaper in France
the president or speaker of the Senate
who's not an extremist
oh good man kind avuncular said the
current situation in the area of
immigration is just not tenable it's not
possible that's the truth of the
situation and you can do what you like
you can no longer accept this and
therefore we have to put up the barriers
that are required here we need to act
quickly we need to have moral legal and
physical borders thank you thank you
very much the next speaker is Mrs Lina
DuPont
thank you very much president
for 10 years we're promising people that
Europe has a common Asylum and migration
policy and
we can stop going from crisis to crisis
for two years the we've had the
commission proposals on the table for
two years two years but we're trying to
find a balance per Town emergency
measures and finding defining a common
basis is necessary
more than ever if you look at our local
authorities if we look at the situation
outside the EU pandemic a brutal um
wall of aggression by Russia the
situation has changed cynically that has
led up a way for an agreement that is
also increased the pressure on
negotiations I think I speak for many
when I say that in this period
we've gone through every emotion you can
imagine and now we're close to an
agreement we're
very close to a solution it's been
difficult work but we can do it why
perhaps that's the reason why
everybody's neighbors nervous this
Smugglers because their business model
is threatened the member states they
agreed the groups because they have to
um
practice real politic but we can do this
together or not at all
so everybody should come together and
perhaps we should stop to um
holding this up because the next weeks
not the months or the the years it's the
the next weeks which are essential let's
roll up our sleeves and and be prepared
for long nights otherwise the powers who
are not
don't wish us well outside the Europe
and those who don't want to have a
solution here
and it is the Smugglers who
um who will be celebrating so this is
the time to act Adam Isabel Santos
please
commissioner
we
need to
consider the response to this Pact
I am in favor of it I support it I think
it is an important
pact which we need to put in place in
order to make progress but there is too
much of a danger
because of the way the writers
approaching this that migrants are
simply weaponized
for nefarious purposes we've got to have
a much more carefully structured
coherent policy we have to have
protection of our external borders and
we need to support the countries of
Transit and origin
it is important that we have shared
responsibility it's important that we
have recognition of Human Rights and we
need to have humanitarian roots of
access for Asylum Seekers
and refugees so we need finally to have
proper solidarity across the member
states we need to have a proper shared
responsibility shared reception
approaches and shared search and rescue
we've also got to move on to have a
proper integration policy so that we can
use the talents of the migrants coming
into our continent this therefore means
that yes we need a pact but we need a
pact which is fit for the times in which
we're living we can't simply be having
it need jerk reactions we is now no
longer in the in the plenary to say that
uh
really using popular population
replacement here is a scandal because
maybe he doesn't find a problem but
simply to recall that um
population replacement has been used by
Breivik for example as a justification
to kill 69 young people in Norway
that's the reality and I have to tell
you Mr Cena's that personally
I think that it's good that we will have
now a deal after eight years because you
first of all with the council try to
find unanimity between the member states
even when the treaty says it's not
necessary unanimity
uh but I think that there are two things
missing first of all a real uh legal
route to enter the European Union a
European legal migration uh framework uh
based on on the blue card and not 27
different systems and the second is uh
giving the possibilities in my opinion
that people can ask for Asylum or
Refugee status in their country of
origin
or in the country of Transit you know
what the drama and the tragedy is that
people need to come to Europe on the
European territory to ask for Isaiah so
why not using our consulates why not
using our embassies why not using an
opening centers in the countries of
origin so there they can ask for Asylum
and if it disagree then they can enter
the European Union and that is missing
in your package thank you very much Mr
hosta next speaker is Mr Damian Peter
the colleagues Minister
um vice president spoke person of the
left
um
we do need a deal and we do need a
system very fast because otherwise we
will hear this kind of fear-mongering
from the right that we heard earlier not
even shying away from Nazi terminology
this is something we have to get over
there's no far-right party that didn't
rise on the topic of migration and
Asylum I think that's very clear but it
does matter what kind of deal we get
what kind of system we get and here I
just want to say that while I'm happy
that maybe we have a crisis position
soon it also matters what's in that
position and to be honest what the what
the member states are currently
proposing doesn't really work I mean
let's look at it jailing people and
children in a camp would have not helped
Italy in lampedusa nor would have have
helped the Asylum Seekers extending the
time of jailing wouldn't have helped
transferring some cash to lampedusa from
other member states wouldn't have helped
so we need to look at the actual system
that we want and that actually works so
A system that works would have fast
decentralized procedures A system that
works which understand that we are one
Union and that we need to distribute
people across the union to not of
borders A system that works would have
understood that integration challenges
and opportunities need to be solved
within integration and not by reducing
the amount of migrants or asylums that
we get here and the system that works
would have a functioning search and
rescue system A system that works
wouldn't put anyone in camps especially
not children we are better than that and
a system that works wouldn't follow
negative rhetorics but understand that
75 percent of people actually getting
assigned decisions at the moment in
Germany are positive so let's work for a
system that works rather than just
closing any deal thank you
we have a blue card for you
constant Bogdan would you accept it yes
we will speak in Polish please please
put on the
headphones
thank you diamond for accepting my
question I have a remark to make
you've been paying a lot of attention to
the right wing and you're saying the
right wing is guilty of all the bad
things that happen but it's probably
your socialist friend a minister in the
Danish government who said a few weeks
ago that the EU must be fenced in why
don't you make a comment of what he said
and you keep on talking about the right
wing who are guilty of all the bad
things you have politicians from
different political groups but you
always start talking it's the right wing
that who are the bad guys it's not fair
it's not honest please comment on what
was said by the Danish Minister thank
you
so I think what I was trying to say and
what I said is that every far-right
party in Europe
has grown on the topic of xenophobia and
migration and Asylum and that is the
truth I also condemn anyone that uses
easy populist Solutions of saying you
know the others are evil and we should
keep them out and it doesn't matter what
kind of party family they're from but
it's definitely true that every far
right politician sitting here has used
this rhetoric and even went so far as to
using Nazi terminology in this house and
that is not okay and that's not
acceptable
thank you very much now we continue with
Mr Patrick Yaki please
thank you president commissioner
let's say it's straight in the face what
are the results of your migration policy
in 2021
every second perpetrator in Spain was a
foreigner every fifth was African and
it's also at The Afghani and the
pakistanis who are perpetrators many
many times more likely to be
perpetrators of crimes people from
Algeria or locals according to research
from 2016 70 of French Mazen won Sharia
law to be introduced in France and what
you are proposing is more of the same
although residents of Europe don't want
it they want to stop illegal immigration
so the question to be asked is why are
you forcing this project because it's
ideological to destroy our Christianity
National States and to win votes for
liberals and the left you only want
power but we are supposed to pay with
our security so my message to you is
polls will stop your migration pact in a
referendum to behold in Poland thank you
thank you very much next speaker Bernard
zimjock
hey president president
mice migration
is now out of control uncontrolled of
Entry of hundreds of thousands of people
has dramatic consequences uh murders
Etc
has consequences but the eu's doesn't
nothing if instead of preventing uh
illegal migration the impact will mean
that will have forced the redistribution
of migrants in Europe
given overpopulation
and a lack of jobs in Africa will have
further masses coming here the EU
through this Pact
one doesn't want to end migration on the
contrary there is being cemented and
promoted I call for a
campaign based on the exam I'll straight
an example and then don't getting in any
migration Australian Australians are not
enriched by any cases of rape colleagues
if
agrees to this tax-financed migration
pact the uh financing those that they
are betraying the interest of those who
have elected them
next
next speaker please
thank you
and then discussing the U.S element
migration package people by default are
going to regulate the issue of
immigration
the case someone is coming from the
Third Country to seeing you but take
your time my country is very fond of
turning codes inside out
lawmakers have figured out a way to
force large groups of permanent
residents to leave the country
first group are locals who were not
recognized as Latin citizens 30 years
ago and later acquired citizenship of
Russian Federation recently
3760 people have received orders to
leave the country by failure to apply
for exam on the latvan language master
but our new old governing party has just
outlined another category
they want to take away latvent
citizenship from these loyal people in
the case it was acquired through the
process of naturalization so I want to
ask Vice President shinas are you ready
to create a special package for the case
of force immigration
thank you Max speaker is Miss Elizabeth
Rosenberg veronidi please
look it up thank you Mr President Mr
Vice President you know that only in
2023 more than 2 500 people lost their
lives or went missing in the central
Mediterranean in the Eastern route and
in the Aegean more specifically
human trafficking and smuggling networks
continue their activities the Greek
government has been successful in
protecting the Greek borders and the
European borders in the last four years
but if
region not combat these illegal network
with a joint and solidary reaction from
all member states we cannot combat the
phenomenon
and how can we Implement these pacts
with countries of origin
we need illegal roots of migration this
is more urgent than ever we have a legal
and moral responsibility to rise up to
the occasion to the challenges and to
the expectations of European citizens
and with the other colleagues we came to
a fair text when we when there's a will
there's a way so we owe the European
citizens a real proof of the fact that
solidarity is a European value and I
firmly believe that if all member states
take their commitments and fulfill them
we could indeed complete The Pact before
our mandate ends thank you schneck
speakers Mr Pedro Silva Pereira please
president
thank you president
there are few decisions which are so
urgent
on the European political agenda as the
adoption of the European Asylum and
migration pact the tragedy that we see
daily in the Mediterranean where more 2
000 people have died since the start of
this year
all this calls for a immediate reaction
to in line with the circumstances this
is a European situation and this
response must be European and this can
only be built on solidarity we need
solidarity with lambidusa and the
countries which are in the front line
and
we must support them in the reception of
refugees and migrants we need solidarity
with the countries of origin where the
migrants come from so that we can tackle
the causes of migration so that we can
be more efficient in dealing with a
Criminal trafficking networks we need
solidarity with migrants and refugees
themselves
and with the help of SAR we must create
legal migration routes so that there are
good possibilities to receive these
people these Spanish Council presidency
has acted well by making this a priority
and I hope it's successful because we
shouldn't pretend the fight between
solidarity and extremist populism is a
question where it goes over life and
death
what ideas
thank you very much president vice
president secretary of state
few doubt
that Dublin 3 regulation is insufficient
for purposes
and therefore we need to have a policy
based on solidarity but also on shared
responsibility for all member states not
just those of us who have external
borders
we need to also Grant Asylum to those
who are fleeing War persecution
and it's part of what we are we want to
help people live a dignified life we
want to help them for the future
therefore we need to have sustainability
in our welfare system
but of course we need to make sure that
we don't get overwhelmed by the
situation that we don't have instability
social instability and we need to be
able to say that
without being lambasted for it we
believe in orderly and regulated
migration
I mean some people want to fear manga
want to spread hate speech
are we only going to hear them no we
should also think about those who are
thinking of Europe's future and for all
of these people we need this pact as
soon as possible if we don't do this if
we fail then I'm afraid it's the people
who've been hearing this morning coming
out with nonsensical things who will be
the only ones heard
and I also have to announce that I will
close the blue card procedure because
we're really running late and I want to
take at least one person for the catch
the eye from each group thank you very
much and please respect your speaking
time really please thank you
thank you very much
10 years ago president barroso having
looked at the endless line of coffins in
that produce I said Europe cannot turn
its back on this yet 10 years hence
Europe does not have a search and rescue
policy worthy of any name indeed search
and rescue operators are criminalized
and immigrants are dying at Sea and in
the desert we are even engaged in
pushbacks at Sea which is utterly
inhumane of course Europe is not perfect
but really we do need to have some
principles and I'm glad to see that
we're agreeing on the crisis mechanism
in principle for redistribution in times
of Crisis but if this proposal is at the
moment blocked it's entirely because of
the Italian government mainstream
populists don't want to make progress
they just want to ferment hatred in
order to win seeds and they want to
engage in attacks in order to hide the
void at the heart of their policy what
is the problem with immigration people
who are fleeing hunger starvation War
half of it which we've caused Anyway by
exploiting with our ruthless capitalism
everything that these peoples had there
is no redistribution of wealth which is
what we ought to see in a green and
socially orientated Market thank you
colleagues two weeks ago on the border
between Bosnia and Herzegovina and
Croatia
shorts uh were fired by migrants and
people Smugglers at Croatian police and
the so-called humanitarian organizations
are not saying a word about it and if by
chance it were the other way around if
the Croatian police had shorted the
migrants these associations would have
been attacking the creation police here
for months on end
so the police who do legal work may not
use weapons
but illegals obviously May
so really we can wonder who is being
crazy here so all of you who encourage
illegal and uncontrolled migration take
those migrants home with you do not
force us to receive them or to pay you
20 000 Euro for each migrant you know in
Croatia a person who has worked and paid
taxes for 40 years has an average
pension of about 500 euro
which means about five six thousand
Euros per year and now we should pay
three times more for one migrant twenty
thousand Euro so get serious really we
need a complete change of the policy
next speaker is here
thank you sir
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
I'm going to project myself into your
world the European Union you know a big
Union can we solve these big problems of
the day
quite frankly I put myself in your place
and I just can't stop laughing since
2015 we've been trying time and time
again to use the same instruments in
order to resolve this illegal migration
crisis same thing every time it's a
complete failure we can see that today
which is the need for a speedy adoption
of the packed on migration and Asylum
again you're trying to use the same
instruments redistribution you're trying
to solve these problems the same way
it's not going to take us any further
eight million people approximately
illegally on the continent
you know you've got the Geneva
Convention they're not allowed a status
according to that convention because of
their circumstances and yet nevertheless
nevertheless you know if they were to
lose their entitlement to stay they
still stay
this is not a solution this is not a
viable solution the only solution was
the one pointed out by my colleague Mr
zabonski a no way policy we need to help
people locally we can't bring them all
to Europe Islam next speaker is Mr Kola
koshish
you call them refugees now they you call
them migrants it is high time to call
them what they truly are
criminals
when croats go to work to Germany when
Germans move to Spain this is the
definition of migrants those who travel
via woods and forests and mountains by
paying Smugglers to cross legally about
10 National borders and if they're
called migrants
only false liberals false greens can
call them such who want to ban plastic
straws and Q-tips to save Europe
from Merkel and her pet founder lion
have almost ruined Germany and they're
about to ruin the rest of us as well you
want to turn us into Sweden today we
won't have it
by direct abuse of social funds uh
you finance the smuggling of millions of
people into Europe
using the money of poor and poor
European citizens we won't have it do
you call it it's not appropriate to call
migrants criminals this is not
acceptable we continue with our
colleague Dolores monserat please thank
you
thank you
very much
thank you Presidente secretary
commissioner president
migration is a common challenge for the
European Union not just for the southern
Mediterranean countries such as Spain
thousands of lives are at stake at the
stability of many regions in the
European Union which are not able alone
to tackle the arrival of many migrants
we have in Spain seen that the canaries
and theater Maria are struggling
search and rescue is rescuing literally
thousands of people every year in 2022
more than 20 000 people were saved from
sea we therefore need to have a common
migration policy based on solidarity to
those who need protection we also need
proper monitoring and control of our
borders so that we can have secure
migration linked to employment and so
that we can finally Vanquish this
scourge of these criminal mafias and
traffickers we've got to stop the
attempts of third countries weaponizing
the movements of migrants to try to
force the hand of the European Union
we've seen this last year and the year
before in posterior tamilia and
elsewhere we need a realistic policy not
just a utopian idea we have really got
to ensure and especially now that Spain
is in the presidency of the EU Mr
Sanchez that we actually recognize that
principles we need to deliver on and
it's not actually allowing an amnesty at
home in Spain for those who sought to
subvert the law it's standing up for the
principles and rights of the citizens of
Europe thank you just an image
foreign
more and more arrivals are seen in
Slovenia the circumstances are serious
but they're worst in the Mediterranean
Milan producer and the canaries
yesterday
we marked the 10th anniversary of one of
the worst
shipwrecks
in our territory
and
the Mediterranean has become the biggest
Mass grave of refugees and more and more
people die there each year we must know
what we must do we must have a root and
Branch reform and this must be based on
Justice and fairness we've done our work
in the European Parliament but the main
element
has to be tackled by the member states
we must act now immediately we must be
not be paralyzed when it comes to
migration
because
it's only Smugglers and and the far
right who benefit from the situation
it's important to adopt this package
before the European elections we can't
have any more failure
thank you vice president uh commissioner
sheeness I was encouraged by a
presentation this morning and you were
able to document genuine progress and
demonstrated real energy to deliver the
pact I do take issue however with the
characterization of the EU Tunisia
partnership the Strategic partnership
has been necessary and workable
we should have known from Libya that
efforts to stop human trafficking
resulted in torture in captivity in
Libyan detention centers we should have
known from border management funding in
other African partner countries that no
serious human rights guard rails are
implementable requests for reports on
human rights impacts of these
Arrangements by MEPS have gone
unanswered by the commission I come from
a country where we had 200 years of mass
immigration now 40 million Americans
claim Irish descent many of them
emigrated in leaky boats and yet there
are many in Ireland who would pull the
ladder up behind them
it is for this and many other reasons
that the pact for all its imperfections
is urgently necessary I hope you and the
council will approach the forthcoming
negotiations with flexibility and
pragmatism thank you merci beaucoup
thank you the next speaker is Francoise
thank you president commissioner
the 13th of September
um
a boat arrived in lampedusa and on the
21st of September the ecj responds to
France a member State doesn't have the
right to refuel a person
who seeks to enter illegally
before an expulsion there has to be a
period for the person to voluntarily
leave the territory so the only thing
that a member State can do is to
politely ask people not to violate their
Frontiers
and there is still a possibility to
invite them not just to stay that's uh
just shows that European law
is turned on his head
the maximum of the procedure the maximum
complexity the maximum in Juris injury
Prudence shows Injustice against the
networks which are made the Cornerstone
of their dirty business it's Injustice
against the citizens of the people and
just democracies can't decide who they
receive or not and to master their
Destiny it's Injustice against law
itself because
it creates a an area of non-law it's
necessary to put law in its proper place
Clayton please
thank you president commissioner
president colleagues tragedy after
tragedy has followed in the
Mediterranean and as Mike followers day
calls for a practical solution have been
voiced but looking back to 2013 when 368
people died in a tragic shipwreck in
lampedusa we have achieved far too
little I was in lampedusa at the weekend
to commemorate the tragedy but also a
sister Bartolo said to try to learn from
it because it is time for the member
states to learn
from the people of lampedusa how to show
Humane humanitarian approach and how to
treat
migrants decently we have got this
shameful Tunisia deal which has simply
fermented
anger and is nothing more than political
window dressing concocted by Miss
funderline and Ritter and Ms Maloney how
many more people need to die before we
can actually put together a pact on
migration that is actually worth worthy
of the name and a top priority of our
time thank you
since 2014
here in the European Parliament have
been a voting in favor of proposals to
deal with the migration and Refugee
issue but nothing
seems to be working
under the junker presidency we had voted
in favor of a very good proposal but
look at the Tunisian
leader who's actually a dictator he did
not allow for the European MEPS to
Center no questions asked
he has complete this regard of the aid
from the European Union because he
thinks that it is
just charity again there is nothing
going on basically we would like to have
a deal with Tunisia but we don't really
have one
what we have do have are some efforts
from Foundry Lyon the European people's
party and Maloney Mrs Maloney it is a
shame that Mr Weber is not here now to
listen to My Views
we all talk about the tragedy in
lampedusa with 400 people dead but what
about the 700 people that lost their
lives off the coast of the peloponnese
this summer why don't you talk about
them don't didn't these people
um have souls didn't their lives matter
this is how dignity is lost in the
European Union Miss Francesca pipucci
thank you
colleagues
how many further deaths do there need to
be in the Mediterranean for member
states to wake up and realize they need
to Shorter their responsibilities
how much longer are we going to play
into the hands of human traffickers
those who are trading in drugs and arms
as well as people's lives how long is it
going to take us to find a commonly
accepted solution migration flows are a
huge problem they're a genuine challenge
to contemporary society and this is not
a chance just for Italy is a challenge
for the entirety of the European Union
and each individual member State nobody
should be engaged in ethical lecturing
everybody has got to shoulder their
responsibility and has got to play their
part it is absolutely Unthinkable that
we do anything else we can't just
abandon a number of countries to
shoulder the whole burden of the
migration policy of the European Union
people are fleeing war and persecution
and coming to the European Union for
goodness sake let's give them a
dignified reception and let's make sure
that we treat them properly on the other
hand Let Us return those who have no
right to be here we've got to have a
proper policy and we have got to enforce
it thank you very much next speaker is
Mr Cyrus Angelo please
thank you Mr President I spoke to a lot
of people in our squares and in our
streets in malt another and in other
countries and you know what they say
about immigration Europe has failed I
spoke to immigrants in detention centers
and in open centers and even they they
say that Europe has failed with respect
to immigration as have said a lot of you
in this Parliament Europe has failed
eight years ago
um eight it's been eight years since the
ministers have been discussing in
Council in our Parliament we have done
our work we have a strong position
reached at a reasonable time but we have
been waiting for a council for the past
eight years I hope that in the meeting
they have this morning they will come
out with a position in the meantime the
commission the commission is putting in
money without the consent of of this
parliament in Tunisian Pockets to try
and close them out the mouths of the
populist on this side of the parliament
but it is useless because we know Syed
hasn't done anything we have seen what
happened in lampedusa in the past few
weeks and months citizens
deserve a solution whatever the
situation Europe is in please
foreign
the right-wing populists are like birds
of prey they are waiting to see
the next tragedy
they actually see this as an opportunity
to stop the migration pact for the EU
they've declared a culture war against
all those who don't look like them
they talk of course about protecting
European civilization using big words
but they are like birds of prey waiting
watching seeing so that they can
actually take over our Union reintroduce
border controls barbed wire they're
prepared to pay in fact for all the
Border guards that we have in order to
stop people coming in because their
dream Society is basically premised on
mistrust mistrust for the other if you
don't have the same background the same
Origins as them you're automatically a
criminal in renew we are fighting for
the survival of Europe but we're
fighting against populists extremists
barbed wire fences walls in my Europe in
my Europe I too have a place I come came
as a child I was a refugee and I came to
Sweden to I belong there to the Swedish
rural area to the European Parliament to
Europe the
Parliament has delivered the commission
has delivered now it's for Council to
deliver don't just let these birds of
prey sit there watch and build barbed
wire fences everywhere Mr Gabrielle mato
okay
thank you president
reporters of Europe are absolutely
overwhelmed in the canaries we are sadly
aware of the implications of all these
arrivals thousands of people are coming
to our islands and we can't actually
have any proper reception arrangements
for them we have endless boats coming to
our Shores more than fifteen thousand
people in a year and there are many who
have tragically lost their lives on the
way thousands of Souls which have
perished attempting to come to our
islands and we don't even have any
proper infrastructure to welcome them
when they're there we don't even have a
proper plan to integrate them into
European Society this is why we need
this new package
immediately we can't afford any more
crises we don't have a properly cohesive
concerted policy to address these issues
and areas such as the canaries simply
can't take on this huge responsibility
for managing a policy which actually
after all affects everybody it may be
that we have a maritime Frontier but we
have got to ensure that solidarity
prevails right across the European Union
in difficult times as well as in the
easier times it's not just a question of
cast thank you
gracias
thank you dear president dear vice
president
the Secretary of State
Mrs Montserrat I Turn to You
you've come here to talk about amnesty
now this is the European Parliament
uh you know I think you need to show
some dignity here we are talking about
the European Parliament and the purpose
of this debate is so important so just a
little bit of dignity now land producer
lamp producer is Europe Europe Islam
producer but managing migratory flows
requires a European response based on
solidarity in full respect of Human
Rights so walls migratory agreements
with Tunisia they're not the solution
let's not delude ourselves it's actually
invention of the extreme right it's not
desirable it's not feasible if we want
to face this migratory challenge with
success we have to show political will
we have to show determination just as we
did with the pandemic Putin's War the
economic and social Fallout from that
the migration Asylum pact is a necessary
pact but not enough in itself we need to
go beyond opening up humanitarian
channels
allowing regular migration and we also
need to step up our cooperation with
countries of origin and countries of
Transit and finally allow me to turn to
the Spanish presidency of the EU I would
ask you to please initiate a rescue at
Sea operation policy for Europe as a
whole please make sure this happens
thank you it's Mr Lucas forlas please
foreign
president Mr commissioner it is high
time we set a cohesive and comprehensive
policy for the migration crisis
countries such as Cyprus were left alone
to deal with such major crisis right now
seven percent of my underoccupation
country
are seeking our Asylum Seekers most of
them are coming from the Turkish
speaking side illegally
we know the consequences we have felt
them we have experienced them but we
need to overcome the obstacles otherwise
we have severe and major crisis
so we need to have a real solution for
this problem and we will stand by your
side a Mr Vice President Lina Olson
please
10 000 individuals arrived in lampedusa
over three days recently lampedusa has a
population of six thousand it's actually
smaller than leading an island in Sweden
200 vessels 10 000 people if they were
to arrive in leadinger over three days
think of the headlines the situation
would have been seen as unsustainable
completely unsustainable and it is
unsustainable
time and time again we are firefighting
but we come in after the event the EU
can't continue like this this is not a
project Europe can't help everyone what
we can do however is take our own
responsibilities the member states of
the EU are sitting around a negotiating
table they are negotiating a policy
that's of course a breakthrough and we
shouldn't underestimate it as that as
that and historically speaking it is
unprecedented but we are still waiting
for Solutions we need to have one common
framework for policies not 20c different
one we have the old pact we need it but
we need to make sure that we have a fair
distribution of responsibility around
Europe so we can have a long-term policy
this yes please
do you have a point of order
president
thank you it was just to say that we
didn't hear
for the last
last statement
thank you thank you so much
benefit
s
thank you very much President yesterday
here in the chamber we commemorated the
10th anniversary of the lampedusa
tragedy
368 women men and children who lost
their lives in this quest for a better
life
it is absolutely terrible to think that
this package on migration Asylum is
still blocked because some people think
that NGO ships are simply encouraging
migration the data shows that this is
not the case
that notwithstanding there are people
from Fratelli desalia in this chamber
who have said absolutely shameful things
between yesterday and today
in the wake of that disaster there was
Mario nostrum we remember what happened
there the marinostrum research and uh
search and rescue mission was
suspended but is now actually being
reinstated we hope but Italy is now
actually trying to criminalize those who
are actually operating search and rescue
and it is actually
failing to recognize that millions of
people need action because too many
thousands of people have lost their
lives over these recent Years thank you
thank you Mr President
while adopting a common policy on Asylum
and immigration is an absolute necessity
to protect those at risk to streamline
or a way to deal with immigration and to
combat
um the way that totalitarian regimes
take advantage of this migratory flows
the policies implemented by the EU in
the past years do not take into account
the real situation in the member states
that are systematically abused and a
flagrant example is the illegal regime
of erdogan who
is utilizing and weaponizing the
migratory flows towards Cyprus and this
is how these people these migrants are
transferred to Turkey from their to the
occupied territories of Cyprus and from
there they uh switch over to the
Republic of Cyprus and this is where in
an organized fashion they seek Asylum
but the vast majority of them are not
refugees so a simple question to Mr
China's how are you going to deal with
this uh problem
in action and in reality please
thank you President yesterday we marked
the 10th anniversary of the lampedusa
tragedy ten years later we saw one
tragedy after another in the
Mediterranean and I asked what have we
learned learned nothing many empty words
many declarations many promises that
were never kept a lot of rhetoric from
the extreme right
who instead of losing themselves in this
rhetoric they should convince their
governments and in the meantime hundreds
of people men women children and babies
continue to die every day in our sis for
many years we have been requesting a
mechanism of solidarity between member
states especially the member states at
the border solidarity that every member
state is supposed to have signed for
when it joined European Union solidarity
that we only use and abuse where we want
and where it suits us
we have to move from words to facts the
European pact on migration and Asylum
must be adopted before the end of this
legislature and we have to do this to
save the lives of so many people and to
protect
border countries from A disproportionate
burden we must also do it in order to
send a message to our citizens that the
European Union is not just a talking
shop but an institution capable of
taking action and leaving a positive
effect now to the catch the eye I have
19 requests we cannot take them all as I
said we take one from each political
group and in the order how they
requested the speaking time so we start
and one minute Tom Vanden candelar
please
test case
ladies and gentlemen migration is a test
for the process of European integration
and the same is true in terms of
acceptance by the citizens of Europe the
migration and Asylum pact will actually
allow us and this process so far has
shown us where there are majorities if
we do not have unanimity
in terms of the letter rather than the
spirit so the question remains as to
whether qualified majority is dead in
the water I think the migration pact
should also allow us to ascertain what
is likely to occur in future
this is
not going to be a further enlargement I
think the people will not go along with
that if we cannot cope at home
commissioner president dear colleagues
the case of migration and what we are
debating today is a clear example of the
fact that we should not take decisions
before
regulation Mrs Merkel has decided
to start my to initiate migration
without discussing with her colleagues
and this is why we have hundreds of
thousands of migrants to whom we are not
able to ensure decent living conditions
this is why it's very important that we
finally come to a pact on migration
clearly regulating what legal migration
is what illegal migration is ending
traffic
because I don't agree with you that we
have a half-built house we have the
house of the urban Union but we must
know clearly how many people can we let
in how can we welcome them and when we
have illegal migration we must reject
because solidarity Moscow hand in had
with the security of European citizens
this is how I believe we must regulate
and I hope that Council will finally
step up and approve this package
thank you very much
soon
80 years ago my father
fled in an illegal fishing boat to
Sweden our European institutions are
built to prevent that once again
we denied the rights of
refugees
and warranty 10 years after land
producer we've been waiting for a
solution it's up to we owe it to Simon
Vale we owe it to those who were
murdered in the camps to have a safe and
fair reception of refugees
368 people lost their lives in the drama
of lampedusa 10 years ago it's now 28
million men women and children uh sorry
28 000 men women and children who have
died without anyone stepping up to
prevent it for 10 years we have seen
hate and anti-immigrant rhetoric
Fortress Europe which is leading to
these dramas agreements about this pact
are relating to obligatory solidarity
between member states but one of the
fundamental criteria for doing away with
this crisis at our borders and for
reception in our countries is to achieve
such solidarity we see border detentions
including of children in Our member
states this is not based on a humane
uh solidarity-based policy we need
to look at what we can do for them not
sending people back not refusing entry
and sending people back to authoritarian
regimes we need to respond with
solidarity and a human Spirit to our
sisters and brothers as we did with
ukrainians
[Applause]
thank you president
up until now Europe has failed when it
comes to migration policy the reason for
this the responsibility of this is
actually to be found at the door of
those who have spoken out uh calling on
the criticizing the close policies of
the right this hypocritical
for many people on the left in Europe
they want to send back pregnant women
children they want to transport refugees
to Rwanda leaving our borders open while
at the same time supporting ngos which
transport illegal immigrants to our
coasts we should reject this immorality
we have very few instruments we should
use them the time really has come to
bring an end to this traffic so we have
to start boycotting this we have a
10-point plan but we seem to be
pretending it doesn't exists enough
we're facing an absolute failure of the
redistribution policy and this means
that the European Mario nostrum is now
being flooded
we seem to be based working the
principle of business as usual this
immune traffic
where the only thing which would save us
it has to stop people leaving the coasts
thank you president a few days ago an
Italian judge let three illegal
immigrants from Tunisia
uh be released saying that detaining
them would run counter to European law
that judge then went on to social media
and talked about salvini and getting
signatures for opening doors to allow
people in not just allow them in but
give them their plane tickets we don't
only have
EU legislation which doesn't work but we
also see politicized judiciaries such as
Italian judges it's a battle for
civilization and Only The Lager is
really fighting this battle our
governments need to understand that the
EU will never solve this problem this
Europe is in submission to the left
those who would encourage such an
invasion Maloney has trusted the EU for
instance with the memorandum on Tunisia
but have been betrayed in 2024 we need
the center right to work together
without entering the Mortal Embrace of
the last speaker
Islam Peter
please thank you one minute Miss Islam
president thank you very much president
for an hour hour from over there I'm
hearing that migrants are criminals I
have to say very clearly at five years
old as a daughter of a political Refugee
I left turkey for Germany I and people
like me aren't criminal but what is
criminal fascists are criminals and of
course we know that from history and we
know above all from the houses that
burned down in German because Nazis want
to kill migrants
president
I find a friend of mine said he wasn't
in the opposition in Turkey he was
because of the erdogan government he was
thrown out of his job his wife also so
now he's just working in a tobacco farm
so his wife is sick and he
fled to Norway on the Balkan route
he was fleeing
from someone with whom the EU has a
refugee deal we continue with Mr Fabio
Massimo castaldo
Presidente
IGN
thank you president
how often have we heard over the last
few years of the the problem of one-off
immigration rather than structured
immigration after many years following
the first people Landing we still
haven't got the measures 136
000 people at the end of September still
waiting for the silencer process
our Italian Islands have collapsed in
the face of the arrivals and we do
deserve a Nobel Peace Prize for what's
been done
the solution
simply can't be to further analyze ways
in which we can close down our borders
what worked with turkey won't work with
Tunisia we can't simply stand back and
watch these flagrant violations brutal
violations of human rights
either we have to devote all energy to
fighting against these problems or
become accomplices of what's Happening
we've had enough of what's Happening
we've had enough of these people
adopting fake positions either we ensure
that European law be respected either we
ensure that we protect solidarity common
mechanisms
always see a collapse of cooperation
with between the European Union and
Africa
we can't simply allow the Mediterranean
to be a cemetery for our values and
ideals it's Mr uh commission vice
president srinas please
thank you president honorable members
let me thank each one of you for your
very rich contribution to this debate
let me tell you from the start that I
have the full respect to all positions
expressed here even the extreme ones our
job since December 2019 was not to
reproduce what we disagree upon but to
create a landing Zone around which we
can all find finally
a solution for our migration problems
everything we do not like about
migration in Europe nowadays is the
direct
immediate consequence of the fact that
Europe does not have a migration in
Asylum system
Moria
lampedusa Canary Islands
these are the symptoms
these are the consequences the root of
the problem is that we need a system
many times some of you would have heard
me describing or packed proposals as a
house with three floors
first floor relations with countries of
origin and Transit we will never be able
to manage internally unless we manage
externally
second floor border management it is
morally politically and legally unfair
to delegate the responsibility for our
external border to the five member
states that geography has put them at
the perimeter of our Union
this is a collective task
floor number three solidarity and burden
sharing
everyone would have to contribute to the
solidarity mix that we would need in a
given situation so that the union lives
up to its name as a union
the problem with this house is up to now
many people member states political
forces wanted to take the lift and go
straight to the floor that they like the
most
those who would prefer the first and the
second would say no need for the third
floor because if we had less arrivals if
we had border management no solidarity
and those who insist on solidarity had
the tendency to neglect the importance
of Border management and strong
relations with countries of origin let
me take this opportunity
to say it loudly and clearly especially
as ambassadors are still meeting on The
Pact in Brussels this house with the
three floors will be built at the same
time
and all floors will be of equal
resistance otherwise there will be no
house
few words on external relations of
migration policy I know this is a
delicate issue
and I have no problem
to admit
that much of the work we did in the past
of countries in countries of origin and
Transit did not succeed
we are the biggest development Aid in
the world and still
we didn't manage to obtain added value
for our development Aid in Africa and
elsewhere
we build enough
highways
airports
most of them constructed by European
construction companies but we didn't
create opportunities for people to have
better lives in the these countries
instead of putting their lives in the
hands of the smugglers in the
Mediterranean now we have an opportunity
to change the paradigma
do partnership agreements that would
create opportunities for the young for
women for those who are most in need
and at the same time mobilize everything
we have not only money but also trade
preferences visas Erasmus scholarships
Europe has to approach countries of
origin with a holistic partnership
viewpoint
and and I share the doubt and skepticism
about authoritarian leaders in our
perimeter I do not live in an exoplanet
I can count democracies in our
neighborhood but I cannot accept also
the argument Often by the same people
accusing us of doing nothing with
countries of origin and Transit and
accusing us again of Contracting
authoritarian leaders when we do
something in order to address their
concerns this cannot happen both ways we
have to assume that we have to work with
everybody but under the very clear
caveat that we will not relinquish our
European values and principles
we do not need a fortress Europe we need
a partner Europe
finally
I found much encouragement in this
debate this morning but the most
encouraged moment
was when the left accused me of playing
in the tune of the extreme right and the
extreme right accused me of organizing
the campaign of the left that's the
biggest encouragement for me we are on
the right track thanks
thank you very much vice president and
now the floor goes to state Secretary
Pascual Navarro Rios please
foreign
thank you very much president
the presidency has done its utmost to
reach an agreement on the Mandate for
resolving the crisis at present
co-repair is engaged in discussions and
it is my hope and indeed I trust that an
agreement will soon be reached it is
taking time to reach an agreement
because it is our conviction that a
broad degree of support from all member
states is necessary
for such an important element of The
Pact more specifically the need for
Rapid application should it prove
necessary
both co-legislators have shown a
constructive spirit
throughout the inter-institutional
negotiations and I believe that we will
be able to reach an agreement in
relation to many issues we still have a
lot of work ahead of us and I would like
to recall before this chamber that we're
still awaiting the parliament's position
on the returns directive we appreciate
what many of you have said that we
should strive for consensus in relation
to most of the proposals on the table we
are doing our utmost in the presidency
to reach a political agreement before
the end of our presidency recent
tensions in relation to migration
demonstrate that we need a common
European migration policy and we have no
time to lose thank you it is now closed
and the sitting will continue with the
formal address by his Excellency Mr
Peter Pavel president of the Czech
Republic thank you